- Well, welcome everyone to
the Lotteries and Democracy Conference.
I'm generously sponsored by Yale ISPS.
We know that many of you have
traveled great distances from
Europe and the other side
of the country to be here,
and we're really, really
happy to have you here.
So I'm going to begin by presenting
work from a book that myself
and Brenda van Coppenolle,
who's over there,
are writing on the historical uses
of lotteries throughout cases in Europe.
But I'm first gonna start broader
by giving you a motivation.
So if you haven't noticed,
democracy is in crisis, right?
Or at least this is a pervasive
narrative, both in academia
and in the policy sphere.
This is very much the case in America,
but also in western democracies in
Europe, all over the place, right?
So we think that democracy is broken
and increasingly there's
lots of reasons why, right?
The rise of extremism,
radicalism in politics,
the decline of parties, strong parties,
and kind traditional party membership.
Campaign finance means that elections are
increasingly bought by wealthy elites,
often kind of non-political elites.
There's a lot of corruption.
There's increasingly
democratic backsliding,
although we're kind of arguing
about when, where, high,
when, where, why, and how to define it.
And also declining trust in institutions.
So across the world, we're seeing people
don't have trust in government.
They don't have trust in politics,
they don't have trust in democracy.
And I'm gonna argue
that the real problem is
that voters neither feel included
nor represented in a system
that's increasingly dominated by elites.
So everyday voters are,
are increasingly set apart from democracy.
Okay? So there are lots of ways to fix all
of these problems, but how
do we fix this last one?
Lotteries increasingly have been
advocated as a solution, right?
So these are all kind of recent headlines.
Can randomly selected citizens govern
better than elected officials?
Should we give power to ordinary people?
Voting undermines the will of the people,
it's time to replace it with sortition.
Okay? And just in case you think
that this is just kinda a
popular topic for op-eds,
you know, it's easy to throw
out sortition in lottocracies,
but, you know, maybe this
isn't a real policy idea.
These are happening all
over the world, right?
So deliberative institutions,
bodies that are selecting
random people to have an
active role in policymaking,
sometimes consultative, sometimes advisory
are happening all over the world
and have been happening
for quite a long time.
So that's Belgium in 2011.
Paris recently in 2023, east Belgium,
Ireland, a lot of democracies
are now innovating
by selecting citizens and
bringing them into policy,
typically paired with
deliberative democracy.
Okay? And so what's interesting,
and we think, you know, all of
these innovations are great,
but Brenda and I set out to write a book
that's very much in the
historical political
economy tradition, right?
And so our book, which is gonna come out
as a Cambridge Elements
in a political economy,
it's called "Lotteries and Democracy".
We are chose to look back
in time at all of the cases
that throughout history, where
actually governing bodies use
lotteries in their standing assemblies.
And the nice thing is that we
can use the historical cases
to give us actual empirical
data on how these work,
how these function, what
worked, what didn't,
why were they put in place,
and why were they dismantled?
And hopefully this can help inform the use
of lotteries in permanent
governing assemblies today.
And in the book, I'm not gonna
present the whole book today,
I'm just gonna give you kind
of a really fun chapter.
But in the book, we assess
kind of whether lotteries
improve representation and
prevented elite capture.
These are kind of the two
main reasons why we advocate
for lotteries or why
policymakers are advocating
for lotteries.
And we also look at things
like implementation,
which is often missed in
these kind of high level
op-eds, right?
So screening, auditing, what's
the composition of the pool?
Are there any selection effects
that we need to deal with?
And so today I'm going
to kind of quickly review
the motivation for why kind
of historical policymakers
and modern policymakers
want to turn to lotteries.
And then we're gonna look
at a natural experiment
of deliberative committees in Denmark.
Denmark wrote their constitution
in deliberative committees.
And so we're going to look
to the past to get kind
of cool results about Denmark.
And then I'll conclude. Okay.
So definitions, at least, you
know, I told all presenters
to define their terms
because we all use kind of
similar terminology, but just to make sure
we're on the same page.
So we're talking, when
we talk about lotteries,
we're talking about the selection
of political representatives by lottery.
Sometimes this is called sortition.
You can call this lottocratic selection,
you can call this selection by lot.
But note that most modern
uses of lotteries involve
some sort of stratified
random sampling, right?
So we're trying to choose
a representative snapshot
of society, but we are
weighting the random sampling on
things like gender, geographic
location, et cetera.
Why do you select people by lottery?
It improves representation
and equalizes access to power.
So people that are not elite have a chance
to be at the table.
It's anti-corruption and it
kind of prevents elite capture.
You can't buy off, at least
not before the election.
You can't buy off
someone if you don't know
who's going to kinda be chosen.
Same with campaign finance.
It eliminates the need
for campaign finance
if you're choosing officials by lottery.
And so these are some of the
reasons why we might want
to use lotteries in
democratic governance, right?
But what's really great, and
this is also kind of a preface
the entire conference, is
that lotteries can be used
to select a wide range of
democratic institutions
and in many different ways.
So for you political
scientists that study kind of
comparative institutions,
it's like electoral law.
You can slice and dice random
selection at different levels.
You can make it permanent,
you can make it not permanent.
You can have hybrid systems
where you have a sortition
chamber and an elected chamber.
There's lots of really interesting ways
to incorporate lotteries
in democratic governance.
And that is actually the
motivation behind this conference.
Today, you're going to see
many, many ways to use lotteries
and ways that we think
can improve democracy.
Yeah. Costas?
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Costas] How would you
think about the lottery
(indistinct), like
choosing how to choose if,
I mean all these debate choice if
system should be choosing itself, right?
So would the not choose that
as would be like some sort
(indistinct) of be self-selective?
- Ah.
- And second question,
would you want to,
would this to examine lotteries
as an intermediate step?
So not like directly going
to selection of congress,
but selecting the committees
or the select right, that goes back
to selecting the juries, right?
- Yep.
- You have the lottery
or the generals for every
public office, right?
They directly selecting
who's the (indistinct)
or whatever they would select
by lottery, the committee who.
- Yep, exactly.
Costas, I love your questions
because our book answers both of those.
So the first our lotteries,
I'm gonna rephrase it.
Our lotteries is stable equilibrium. Yeah.
Alan, do you have a two finger? Yeah.
- [Alan] When the first time
a person asks a question
or says something, can
they introduce themselves
and just just say like from (indistinct).
- Yeah, great idea, Alan.
Thank you. Costas, please
introduce yourself.
- [Costas] (indistinct)
- Okay, great. Thank you
Costas. Great questions.
So one our lottery's a stable equilibrium
and we actually show in
the book that lotteries,
and this is not a chapter
that I'm going to present,
but it relates to the roles of parties.
I'm gonna discuss the role of parties in
this historical case quite a bit.
It is the case
that we found historically
lotteries work best kind of in
new democracies, in unstable environments
where you don't have strong
parties to control selection.
So it's kind of a rule that
everyone can agree upon
to organize the society
because it's fair, right?
Lotteries are fair, they're
irrational, you know,
it's not the the strongest
or someone from this part
of the Italian city states
controlling, you know, the currency.
We like choosing by lottery.
However, we show,
and actually the third
Republican in France is
a great example of this.
We have a JOP in a world
politics on this that show
that parties were fine with lotteries
for decades while they were weak.
As soon as parties got strong,
you want to be able to choose
access to committees, you
want to be able to choose
everything so they take them away.
And we argue in the book that
this is actually important
to realize that it's not
the case that parties,
especially strong parties,
you know, hundreds of years,
thousands of years later, right?
Are won't necessarily allow this rule
to kind of supplant them.
And so in the panel we're gonna
talk about the relationship
between parties and lottocracy
and is it going to be a
productive relationship or not?
So no, it's not a stable
equilibrium, at least not
what we can tell from
the historical cases.
And then we do in the book study
what we call lottery based procedures,
which is where you're selecting,
you're using a two stage process,
you split the chamber into random groups.
Those random groups then
elect a representative.
So you don't choose the
representative by lottery,
but you choose the groups by lottery
and then they elect the person.
And even that like kind
of intermediate step,
we show improves representation
and gets people onto committees
that wouldn't have before.
So even a little bit of lottery helps,
but I'll go back to that in a second.
Great question, though, Costas.
Okay, so you can, lotteries can be used
to select a wide range of
democratic institutions
and they have been, right?
So the deliberative wave.
And what's interesting is, you know,
last night at dinner we were
kind of comparing notes like,
oh, have you heard about the Paris one?
Oh, have you heard about Milan?
Is doing now deliberative democracy?
Have you heard about, you know,
what's going on in New York or California?
This is such a burgeoning field
that this is actually outdated.
So this is the OECD keeping
track of all these kind
of deliberative initiatives.
And again, deliberate
democracy uses lotteries
to choose the citizens that
are involved in the debate
coming together to kind of debate policy
and then provide recommendations.
This is only till 2021,
but as you see, you know,
we're at the beginning
of a very steep incline.
So all of these institutions
are something we really need
to pay attention to, right?
Now, what's interesting is that,
so most of these are involving citizens,
although there are some exceptions.
Paris and Belgium are exceptions
where they're incorporating
politicians to work
with citizens in kinda
these liberal committees.
But most of these are citizens
and a lot of our academic
research are focusing on whether
everyday people learn, have
positive participation,
change their minds, you know,
have more trust in government
after participating.
But Brenda and I are actually
interested in the historical
cases where we're at higher levels
with permanent governing assemblies,
with actual politicians, right?
And so that's what our book is focused on.
And prior research also
sometimes is a bit kind
of prescriptive and
hypothetical, which is great.
We need normative theorists
and philosophers thinking about, you know,
the core definitions of democracy.
But Brenda and I are empiricists.
And so we think that we
can use kind of real data
and statistical analysis to
hope, hopefully shed light on
how lotteries work at
very high levels, right?
And high levels of decision making
with professional politicians,
with political parties,
we don't necessarily think that some
of the great findings
from citizen assemblies
would transfer up.
And so for political science professors,
all the political science
professors are nodding.
If you've ever dealt with
politicians like these
might be the slowest to update.
And so our book looks at
politicians, high levels
with actual governing stakes.
So they were choosing the
currency, they were choosing
the budget, how the budget
would be allocated in France,
they were writing the constitution, okay?
And Costas, your lottery based procedures
show up in the book.
They show up in the 19th
century French case.
The cases that we look
at, we look at a lot
of different historical cases
that each use lotteries
in a different way.
So the book is pretty expansive.
We look at ancient Athens,
which was, you know,
more of a lottocracy where
they're actually selecting
the officials.
We look at medieval Italy
where they chose the
standard bearer in Florence.
They were choosing, again,
economic kind of leaders.
Denmark and France. We
look at constitutions.
So France and Denmark wrote
their constitutions in
deliberative groups like,
you know, kind of mimicking
the citizens' assemblies that
have provided advisory powers.
But again, these are politicians
writing the constitution
and then the lottery based
procedures in 19th century
Europe, which is this two
stage selecting committees.
So I'm gonna talk about Denmark today,
but importantly our book
shows that there's a lot
of different ways to
incorporate lotteries.
And again, our big findings are
that generally they do improve
representation if you can keep them.
Okay, I kind of went over
this, so I'll go quickly,
but we do overall, we do find that kind
of across the cases it
does lotteries do improve
representation, but it
also depends on the pool.
So one thing that's
kind of missing from all
of these policymakers
and all of these op-eds
saying we should go back
to a sortition, if you want to
undermine lotteries, you mess
with the pool that they're
originally chosen from.
And that's what Greece did, right?
So ancient Athens, the
pool was restrictive,
it was not everyone in
the polity, you know,
it was effectively elites.
So if you restrict the pool
and then randomly select,
you don't get the,
necessarily the benefits of
increased representation,
although it can still be kind
of anti-corruption, right?
But, so we need to take a step back
and that's some of the projects
I'm working on this year
while I'm visiting Yale to
think about self-selection
to lotteries and think about
how to make the pool expansive
but also tractable to
kind of scale up, right?
Yeah. Kevin.
- [Kevin] Sorry, Kevin
Elliot, Yale and (indistinct).
So when you mean represented
represented here, you mean
the groups that are selected will look
more like the body as a
whole, is that correct?
- Yeah, and in particular, like
trying to think about groups
that would not normally be
in politics if, you know,
typical elites and
elections were in place yet.
Anyway, so pay attention
to the pool, right?
It's, again, you can have a great policy
but if you mess with a
step before the policy,
it can undermine the
benefits of the policy.
Yep, it does prevent elite capture,
but strong parties will
dismantle lotteries,
at least in the night in Europe.
That's what happened.
And yes, we can learn from implementation.
So things like screening,
auditing, you know, giving
individual representatives
chosen by lottery help
and support, all of that would
be important if you actually
want to bring lotteries up
to governing assemblies.
But anyway, so that's kind of the preview
of the findings of the book.
But today, for the next 15 minutes or so,
I'm going to talk about
whether a historical case can
teach us about deliberative committees
and deliberative committees
are when you're kind of
bringing citizens and
politicians to debate,
discuss, and make policy recommendations.
But policy recommendations
that will influence policy
in, are more advisory.
So we're gonna look at the creation
of the June constitution in Denmark.
This is the constitution that
governs Denmark to this day.
So if we're thinking about high stakes,
this was not a temporary document.
They wrote the, this document
existed, it's been amended
of course, but in these
deliberative groups
and we're gonna exploit
a natural experiment
that created these groups
and we're gonna see if they did anything.
And we're gonna measure
whether they did anything
by looking at voting on
constitutional amendments.
So did people get more democratic
as they deliberated into this groups?
And we test whether kinda
this group assignment thing,
you have this group
assignment as a treatment
affected your legislative behavior.
And another great thing about this case is
that obviously we have no
survey measures self-reported.
Did you have a great time
Danish politicians in the 19th century?
Delivery of these groups.
We can't do that.
But we have what's even better,
which is we have the votes,
which would be consequential, right?
You can say you had a great
time in a deliberative exercise
and then not change your mind,
your behavior, or your attitudes, right?
And I'm not saying that's
happening in modern day citizens
assemblies, but the nice thing is
that we have actual costly outcomes
to measure using this historical case.
And then we're kind of speaking
to theories about
deliberation in mixed groups.
This is a very short list,
but you know, there have
been mixed findings.
Sometimes you think that if
you get into deliberative
groups, you're exposed
to different viewpoints
and you moderate, you learn,
you become less polarized, less cohesive.
We've had experimental work show this
and we've had observational
work show this.
But it's also the case
that, you know, exposures
to different viewpoints might reinforce
your existing opinions, right?
You might double down or just might
not change your opinions.
And again, we have very few studies that
use actual politicians
and the studies that do use
actual politicians in Ireland
where they've had deliberative
committees before,
often show that politicians
are kind of less likely
to moderate and less likely to change
because they have
different concerns, right?
They're very concerned
about public relations
and the PR consequences of
participating in these
deliberative committees.
But again, does that translate
into actual policy change
or do they just fall
back to partisan lines?
There's, you know, they're less kind
of happy results when you use politicians.
So these are the literature
that we're speaking to, okay?
Denmark, 19th century. So
that's the constituent assembly.
Obviously all of our politicians are men
because, you know, history.
Okay, Denmark was kinda
an interesting case
of democratization.
So Europe was facing a wave
of revolutions in 1848,
Denmark was at war.
The Danish king saw the
way the wind was blowing
and decided to cede the country
to create a democratic republic.
He was called Frederick the
Beloved because of this.
So he did very well in history.
But it's a bit unusual case
that Denmark didn't get kind
of toppled by a revolution
like France did.
The Danish king was like, "Uh uh, okay,
let's create a constituent assembly.
You know, I'll stay a
constitutional monarch,
but let's create a constitution," right?
So this happened in 1848
and the constitution was adopted in 1849.
So we're talking really about a year
and kind of a smaller period
for deliberation voting.
And there's a lot of, there's
some good work on kind of
roll call voting in the case.
But generally there's not a
lot of studies on this case,
which maybe because it's not conflict
or war oriented, it was
a peaceful transition.
So everyone studies France
and not Denmark. Okay?
So the parties, parties are
gonna play an important role
and this is a great case
because the parties
were weak but existing.
So they stood on ideological platforms
or they had labels for
themselves when they ran
to be elected to the constituent assembly.
But luckily for us, the
blocks are pretty traditional.
19th century Europe, you know,
the left was a movement of rich farmers.
They were not peasants,
but they wanted democracy,
they wanted representation.
The national liberals were the ones
that actually pushed for the constitution.
These are kinda the
merchants in the cities.
They want democracy, but
they kind of want to run it.
They don't want the
rich farmers to run it.
So they're like medium pro-democracy.
And then you have the right,
which are aristocratic,
buddies with the king.
Everyone has accepted that
we need to have a democracy.
But there's a spectrum on how
inclusive, how democratic,
how much the king has
power to really kind of
dissolve the assembly.
And so that's where
they're gonna be fighting
over in the constitution.
Okay? And parties were
parties, institutions were new
and weak, right?
So they said, "Hey, let's
look at what France did.
France had a solution for kind
of an unstable environment
and that's how France
did their constitution.
Let's do that."
And so anti-democratic elites,
they were worried about
kind of blocking democracy.
So they decided to use lotteries.
So they used these random
deliberative groups
and the rationale, and we can see
that from the parliamentary debate.
So why did they put this rule in place?
It was to expose members
to crosscut debate,
to make people get into a
room with other parties,
other members that they didn't know
to let ideas flow better.
So exactly the same rationales
we have today. Okay?
So our constituent assembly has 157
elected or king appointed members.
Five of them went off to be minister.
So it ends up being 152. We
have five deliberative groups.
So they deliberate in groups of 30 or 31,
which is relatively large.
But they stayed in these
groups the whole time, right?
So we're gonna kind of
exploit these groups
to see if over these kind of
six months there was learning,
they debated the constitution draft
and then we have the roll call
votes in the general assembly
where they voted on each of
these parts of the constitution.
And again, three parties.
And then the king was
kind of a background.
The king actually appointed
deputies to make sure
that there were folks
protecting his interests
because the election for
the constituent assembly
went really left.
But because the king interfered,
you basically have equal numbers
of each block across the chamber.
Okay? So what we're trying
to ask using this case
is do po-, you know,
does policy deliberation in
randomly assigned groups affect
voting behavior on the draft constitution
with the hypothesis is that
if these randomly group,
randomly assigned groups expose members
to these new viewpoints, we
should see behavioral change.
The way we decide to
operationalize this is
by looking at the number
of left wing deputies
or here I'm gonna show you the share
of left wing deputies in
your group with this idea
that they were the most democratic.
You know, if you were a
liberal or a right wing deputy
and you were exposed to more
of these left wing deputies,
you would maybe move to closer to them.
That is a choice, that
is a substantive choice.
We also look at the number of
right-wing deputies, right?
'cause you might be affected
by the other tales. Yeah, Kevin
- [Kevin] Was universal men in suffrage.
Was that, was that on the table?
- Yeah, that some of the
votes that we have were
the titling land
requirements for suffrage.
And so, and it works
exactly like you think,
the rich farmers wanted
inclusive suffrage and then,
you know, the right wanted like
only very, very rich elite.
Yeah. So they have like a
series of votes, which you know,
spoiler alert, the rich farmers lost.
Yeah. Okay. So we use a lot
of cool historical data.
So we use the parliamentary records,
we use the roll call voting.
We go look to see whether
they, these individual
parliamentarians had served in politics
before, whether they
were nobility, all sorts
of really cool rich micro data.
If you have questions,
I'm gonna skip over that.
But it's nice.
And again, we're gonna look
at 44 roll call votes on
the amendments to the constitution.
We coded these, we went
and looked at the substance
and we coded these as
pro-democratic or not.
And these are suffrage,
whether the king can dissolve
parliament, you know,
we use 19 of them that
are really, really clear.
Like if you're voting for
an increase in who can stand
for office, you are a
pro-democratic or not.
And there's, I can go into details
if anyone has those questions.
And then again, our
treatment is a, the member
of this random group composition,
the share of left deputies.
Okay? And this is, you can kind
of see the variation
we're exploiting, right?
So here these are the party blocks.
So blue is left, yellow-orange
is center and right is the,
or sorry, red is the right.
And then you have some
free shooters independence.
It's kind of fun. In Denmark
they called them free shooters
if you were an independent, but
they kind of do their own thing.
So typically we're only
looking at the blocks.
But you see variation, right?
Can you see this mouse? Yeah.
So here this group has
a very small proportion
of leftwing deputies.
This group has kind a plurality portion
And we're trying to see if
deliberation in this group versus
this group, namely the
number of left-wing,
pro-democracy people in your
group changes your mind.
Okay? And this is a
legislator vote panel dataset.
And again, we're exploiting the fact that
the group assignment was random.
Okay? So now to get to the results.
So we first look at cohesion.
This is just descriptive to see if,
if you're debating with the same people.
So this is kind of like
if I, if we randomly
move you guys all to tables
and you spent six month debating,
would Costas and Dmitri,
you know, vote with
each more likely to vote
with each other?
Or would this table vote with each other?
Not parties, but your assigned group.
And so one, two, three, four, five,
these are each of the assigned group.
And the x axis is effectively time.
And this is a rice index.
So the higher the rice index,
the more cohesive you are.
And as you can see, nothing,
nothing mildly negative.
So it's not the case that you, you know,
form a group identity with
your deliberative groups.
Even though you're in these
groups every day debating these
constitution, you tend to
vote kind of however you want.
Yeah. Kenzie.
- [Mackenzie] I'm Mackenzie
Locker, (indistinct) ISPS.
How much time actually goes on
between the 40 roll call votes?
Like is that months, weeks, days?
- Yeah, so it's about six months.
So it's kind of starts in
January and then ends in May.
And you'll see like if,
you know, for those of you
who study kind of parliamentary behavior,
you'll see kind of cluster.
So it's not like they had one every week,
they did all the suffrage ones
and they debated for a while
and they did all of the, you know,
and we kind of, you know,
you can look to see,
we don't think that time
is really, you know,
playing a huge role, which
is why it's not, you know,
it's a indexes of vote.
Not like a weekly because they were
kind of three clusters, right?
But good question.
Okay, we see minor
effects for party blocks.
So again, this was
deliberative group flat lines.
You know, we'd expect it to be positive.
If we thought that there
was a group identity,
here we see kind of mildly
positive again over time.
So like the left is a
little bit up center, right?
This is also, again,
these were new parties.
The democracy didn't exist yet.
They were creating it.
But we see a little bit more of an effect
for parties than we do
deliberative groups.
Okay? And now results.
And so here you're going to see
the dependent variable we're trying
to predict is pro-democracy voting.
And the, I'm gonna use this,
I'm not gonna move,
but I'm gonna use this.
This is the coefficient we care about,
which is the share of left deputies.
Okay? And we're gonna look at
this panel first two models,
one with individual
controls, one with not.
But again, we're exploiting
the random assignment of the treatment.
Nothing. Nothing. And
pretty close to zero.
So there's no effect of the number
of left deputies on your voting behavior.
There is an effect of what
party you're in, right?
So compared to the left.
So the left is the base case here,
the center and right were less
likely to vote for democracy.
So that that follows, right?
So here, what's this showing is
that the deliberative group is
not having effect while early
partisanship is.
If you conceptualize this differently
as the number of right
deputies, so you swing over
to the other tail,
again, we have no effect.
And again, you see the left
and some of the center are more likely
to vote for democracy.
But I'm gonna show you a difference,
which is looking at
heterogeneous treatment effects.
Because we would imagine that, you know,
if you're a left wing deputy,
the number of left wing
deputy is not gonna
change you 'cause you're
already with them.
So we split them into what party you are.
So this is only left deputies.
Are they affected by either the share
of left deputies or right deputies?
Nope. Only center deputies.
Nope. Only right deputies. Nope.
Okay, so a lot of 'em,
nope. What does this mean?
We do other robustness 'cause again,
we're kind of limited
by, it's a small sample.
You know, that's the
downside of historical cases.
The data we have is the,
or the data I've shown
you is the data we have.
We do do randomization
inference to see kind of
how likely these null results would be.
And it kind of does support our claims.
We do a couple other things,
but generally we don't have
evidence using this historical
case that these deliberative
groups were significantly
impacting these high stakes votes, right?
And so what we think
and what we think that this
historical case can teach us
about modern day lotteries.
So we do find partisan effects
and even early partisan effects.
And again, you know, if
you're a political scientist
and you study how deeply
rooted partisan identity is
and the incentives of politicians to
represent their constituents
or just pursue their own policy
preferences while in
office you might see this
and say, yeah,
like why would these deliberative
groups have an effect
if they came into the constitution
wanting to observe their goals?
You know, maybe, maybe
this is not surprising,
but it is important because
again, this is a study
of actual politicians
over a long period of time
debating something that was high stakes.
So we think that this is a
really nice historical case
to inform and teach us
about how politicians would,
would work with maybe lotteries today.
And again, you know, we need
to be a little bit cautious,
although I think we need more research
in higher level bodies.
And it's great to see all
of you practitioners here,
I'm gonna talk to you about
this later, but finally,
and we'll get back to this
at the end of the panel,
the lottocracy literature
doesn't know what
to do with parties, right?
So at the very best they say,
you know, well they can exist
as extra parliamentary
organizations, parties don't have
to leave if we have a congress
chosen entirely by lottery.
But it is the case that these
professional politicians
with well-oiled machines,
and Dmitri's work actually
talks about this, could still
influence politics and we
should assume that they will
still try to influence
politics and hybrid systems
that combine politicians and citizens.
These are going to be
powerful players with maybe
preferences that won't
be as easy to moderate.
Doesn't mean we can't do it,
but we need to be aware that
at high levels, you know,
citizens might be more likely
to update than politicians.
Okay. So I'm gonna conclude there
and take any questions you
might have about lotteries,
about Denmark or just
in general discussion.
Do what you will. Yeah, Kevin.
- [Kevin] All right,
thanks. So this is more like
a suggestion I suppose.
So yeah, I totally agree with you about
(indistinct)
and lottocracy not really
knowing what to do with parties
and I wonder what theorist,
democratic theorist.
(indistinct)
But I wonder to what extent
just what's operating here.
I wonder, as if I'm not loud enough. Okay.
- It's good. I can hear you great.
- [Kevin] Yes. So, and the,
I guess the tape does. Right.
So, my question is basically
about representation, right?
So I asked about this before
'cause I think one of the things
that might be happening here is,
and I mean I think I've
read a lot about this that
lottocrats insofar
as they're thinking about
representation at all,
which I think some,
there's a lot of division
within the debate about this.
- Yeah.
- Some lottocrats will say
we are trying to, like,
representation has failed.
We're going to a form
of direct democracy that
circumvents represent altogether.
Because that was the problem
of your original conception
of like, the problem is voters feel
that they're being governed
by disconnected elites.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So what we wanna do
is eliminate elites.
That position, there's been a lot
of pressure put on that position, right?
Within the literature. Our
colleague here at Yale,
Len Landomour has kind of
moved sort of away from
that position and toward a
position that's like, no, no,
the randomly selected citizens conceive
of themselves as representatives.
But it's a different
kind of representation.
And so that's what I would
sort of wanna suggest here
that maybe an, I mean
one of the fault lines
that's running through here,
I think is that parties are
simply approaching or
are in a way based on
a completely different
conception of representation
in democracies, what is representation?
It's electing more or less ideological
or programmatic groups who
are going to govern in line
with those promises
and lottocracy, well,
we're gonna have ordinary
people think about the issues
or something, right?
It's like a, again, there's
sort of working on what exactly
that means.
So like I said, it's not so
much a question as a comment.
I wonder to what extent
though that you, you know,
you see this, you could
imagine seeing elements
of this play out if you do some
kind of substantive analysis
of the debates where
it's like, look, I'm here
to represent the interest of
the groups that I'm a part of
or the party as opposed
to, oh yeah, you know,
you make a good point
and so I'm gonna abandon
my party's position because
we are here to like,
deal with the issues
in this unmediated way.
I think that's more of the conception
that lottocrats have had coming out
of the deliberative tradition.
And that you talk about here, right?
Like when you, when
you would expect people
to change their minds, it's
because they're arriving into
the decision space with a different task.
Are we considering the issue substantively
or are we bringing some kind
of authorization with us?
Or something like that. Sorry.
- No, that's a really great point too.
And everyone should meet Theo.
So Theo's postdoc associated with the,
the Democratic Innovations program
and works with Ellen.
Theo is doing a conference
and studying exactly that, right?
Because they've found increasingly
that even if you're chosen by lottery
citizens feel like they have a job to do.
Like they were chosen to, again,
represent, represent something.
And it's kind of interesting
'cause are they chosen,
you know, like a politician
elected in a district has,
you know, very clear
mandates like schools,
stuff for that district.
Those are the people that're
gonna elect them versus
someone who's chosen by lottery.
They feel like they need
to be representative,
but sometimes it varies by person.
So they need to represent
their class, they need
to represent their geographic area.
But it's much, it's much more expansive.
But there still is a
level of responsibility.
And so that's what Theo's working on.
So everyone go talk to Theo,
he'll be here at some point.
So I think that's true.
And what's interesting is,
so like in the historical cases, you know,
we're looking like Brendan
and I are looking at a wide range.
And what's interesting is like the idea
of representation also changes, right?
So like from ancient Greece
to then 19th century Europe,
like 19th century Europe
politicians, they were like,
well I know best I'm going to do these,
but these were elites who
thought that, you know,
we are kind of in the era of should,
should citizens even be
involved in this, right?
So they had an idea of a mandate.
But the mandate was, you know, I am elite,
I can decide this for the people.
But there still was kind of
this idea of representation.
And we had, so the, one
of the policymakers that was
instrumental in setting up
the Belgian committees was
here a couple weeks ago.
Jonathan Movic super,
super interesting work.
And he was talking about also
it depends on the politician.
So some politicians that
have participated in these
deliberative committees
and the politicians can
self-select in, which is important.
So the citizens are chosen randomly,
but the politicians who work on the issue
or who want to do that self-select.
So again, the selection effect.
So, and theoretically these
politicians would be the one
who are interested in this, wanna learn.
Some politicians are, you know,
they believe in the cause.
They believe in this type
of democratic innovation.
They believe in the structure,
they believe they can learn something.
So they go into it being open to updating
and open to listening to citizens.
And they said other
politicians are doing it
for the photo op basically.
And so that's not a
politician versus citizen,
that's variation within
individual politicians.
And what's interesting is that in Belgium,
it's the green party, or at least the,
Jonathan was working with the green party.
So the climate, the
liberal, like, you know,
those politicians really
believe in the cause
and are kind of open to
it while other politicians
doing other topics are less.
So some of this might not be as level as
it might be individual
variation, like, you know,
convince politicians that
this is a good exercise,
maybe they will be less likely
to dominate the discussion.
'Cause that's, they surveyed the citizens
after the Belgian experiment
and some of the citizens were
like, yeah, politicians like to talk
and they like to dominate the conversation
and they're skilled, right?
If you think about juries, right?
You know, some folks are, you know,
professors are maybe often
we're on fewer juries
because is our job to convince
people that we're right.
And maybe that would not be
great in like a, a jury system.
But yeah. Great questions
Kevin. Yeah. Dmitri.
- [Dmitri] (indistinct)
Do you have a sense of
how much pressure these members
of parliamentary readily
selected groups were from
their respective parties
to maintain the party line?
How much that might have affected
the outcomes you're observing?
- Yeah, so what's interesting is that,
'cause you know, you look at like the,
there were weak parties
where they had kind of labels
and we assume, you know,
like the historical record,
it seems to indicate that
they did kind of like caucus
and especially like the king
appointed deputies kind of had
a different mandate, right?
But the problem is that there
weren't, the records are kind
of like the historical data is a bit,
so like were there party meetings?
Did they meet by the water cooler?
Did they meet in the tavern
and conceptualize themselves as a party?
There wasn't any kind
of whipping or sticks
and carrots that a party
institution could use
to make their members vote.
It was more kind of ideological
kind of preferences.
And if you think about
like kind of Krieble's
wheres the party?
Like at least you know,
parties didn't have a lot.
So anything that kept them
together would've been
either shared preferences
'cause they want all
the stuff for themselves
or kind of these networks
where they all knew
each other and they did.
And you can see if you
do roll call scaling,
like it's, those three
groups are visible across
the additional votes that
are not pro democracies
'cause they were fighting a war.
So there's military votes
and they were cohesive,
like they were doing
stuff kind of together.
And there wasn't, you know,
there wasn't a lot of things
that parties didn't
have access to anything
'cause this was just a
constituent assembly.
But past that, we're not sure
to what extent there were like
extra parliamentary meetings
to help coordinate behavior. Yeah.
- [Dmitri] Do you have a, do
you have any evidence of like
pamphlets, party pamphlets
being put out at that time
articulating, you know, a party position
or particulating a particular platform?
These pamphlets being
written maybe by activists
or by people who were influential
with a party leadership,
anything that would suggest attempts
to maintain a particular party line in
the broader discursive context?
- So the only thing that I remember is,
or the closest thing to that would be,
so I told you the constituent assembly
went to the left, right?
So the, they had this election
for this constituent assembly, you know,
electing these deputies
and the rich farmers,
the society for friends
of the peasants mobilized.
So they had kind of, they had soap boxes.
They were like, oh, we want
our interest represented.
That's why they did so
well in the election.
And the king and the elites were
like, where'd you come from?
Wait turnout, we need to turn out.
Like these peasants have never turned,
or these kind of farmers in rural
areas have never turned out before.
And that's why the king
had to get involved
and be like, well you
actually won the election,
but here are my people.
Let's like, even the scales,
but it was on the left, it was on the ones
that would be the most
pro-democratic kind of early
and exactly like you think
like the cadra parties
and the extra par-,
the grassroots parties,
like the reason the left.
But they were, they were the most in terms
of pushing for the democracy.
While the other two parties
like, you know, a lot
of historical record were much looser.
Like they wanted to
protect their own power,
but they were used to being in power.
So the idea that you had to mobilize
totally shocked them in the beginning.
Yeah. But we could look at that more.
That's actually a good,
that's a good idea.
And you can do text analysis
with all like the debates and stuff.
We have not, but there's now OCR
and digitization is getting better.
So you can actually look to
see, you know, if you're not,
if voting is not the best outcome
to measure, how else could you measure?
You could maybe measure speeches.
So maybe they have to vote
the way they were going to,
but if you have any evidence
of changing their mind,
maybe the language that they use
changes as a function of this group.
But that would require a bit more thinking
like how to measure them.
Yeah. Kevin. Yep.
- [Kevin] So in the Irish
case, right, in the first one
that they had, it was a mix
of citizens and politicians.
- Right.
- And it was precisely issues
that split the parties, right?
So whatever the official
position was of the party,
the whole point of why they
were kicking the decisions over
to the citizen assemblies
'cause they didn't really have
unified positions that split,
that neatly divided the parties.
They were kind of like, we don't want
to make this decision about abortion.
We don't wanna make
this, I forget which one,
if it was marriage equality
or abortion, the first one,
they were, they don't
wanna make this decision.
Yeah, it splits our parties.
So it'd be interesting
to see there might be
variation in both, right?
- And then that's also
kind of like a third party,
like, oh, we're divided.
What are the citizens say?
You know, if they would, if
they had done that for Brexit
before the UK parties
made the biggest mistake
of this generation, like
maybe we would not be,
maybe UK people would not
be in the state you're in.
Yeah. Brenda.
Brenda, can you get the mic?
Where's the.
- Thank you. Hi, I'm
Brenda from (indistinct).
So one thing I would add
to that is that the picture
that you didn't show today,
but that we also have about
roll call scaling shows
that these parties great.
Yeah. That's the one.
Shows that these parties are not clearly
distinct and apart, right?
So there's some overlap
between some individuals
and that's really good
evidence for the fact
that you don't have these parties really
imple-, like imposing their party lines.
- Yeah.
Christian.
- [Christian] Hey, I'm Christian Grosser.
I'm the University of Southern California.
And you mentioned upfront about
the selection into the
deliberative processes
and choosing citizens broadly
as more representative
as you've defined it.
What were the other ways to pick people?
Like did they choose on
competence or expertise
or who the parties wanted?
Like can you just talk
a little bit more about
the selection in when it wasn't truly
random of all citizens?
- Yeah, I mean, so in
some of these early cases,
I mean like elections
weren't like they were today.
Like sometimes they were indirect
or the elections were only, you know,
if you think about like the British cases,
the Victorian vote buying,
you know, so most of the time
when we're comparing
lottocratic selection,
like the baseline would be
election if we're talking
about like choosing individuals
to sit in a representative body.
Once we're in the assembly, typically,
so like if you didn't choose
who was on the budget committee
using this kind of two step procedure,
it would be parties, right?
It'd be party groups and of those parties,
it would be elites in the parties,
like the party leaders or
like the high level people.
And actually we show in the
French case that parties,
you know, they use this
lottery based procedure
to choose the most powerful committee
like the one that controlled the money.
And then once parties got
strong, they dismantle it
and then went back to parties
choose who go on the budget committee.
And you can see that like
the general representation
of the budget committee, like
the average, you know, what,
who was on it, like where
they were coming from,
their background drops, right?
So elites go back on as
soon as parties can choose.
Now there's kinda a larger
question here, which is,
you know, the idea that parties
can use these committees as,
you know, sticks and carrots
that might be good for parties,
like using random selection
for committees takes
that away from parties.
It also takes the ability of
people to develop expertise.
So there are trade offs
actually, either it's not,
we don't think parties are bad.
Sometimes parties can use
this to like build seniority,
but it is the case, at
least in the European cases
that we studied that, you
know, we were kind of like
the middle class deputy
was on the budget committee
and then once parties got it,
it went back to being elites.
But one thing that I'm looking at,
and I will end on this
point is, so, you know,
when we're thinking about how take up,
and this is, I'm working on a survey
experiment to kind of tease this out.
But if we're thinking about take up,
so I randomly invite you
all to a citizens assembly,
you know, I, and we make
sure that there's, you know,
female from Texas, you know, they say no,
we find another female from Texas.
They say yes, right?
If there is an unobservable
that has nothing to do
with the random sampling that
makes the one that said no
not liking democracy, kind of a dissident
and the one that said yes,
just already predisposed
to likes citizens assemblies sort of,
to have different outcomes.
I mean, that might happen that, you know,
from a practical side, like we
can't, you know, control all
of the unobservables that
would make people wanna give up
their weekend to talk about climate.
But interpreting our findings,
we need to understand
more about this selection
because it's not the case.
The invitation is random,
the take up is not random.
And the more we understand take up
and what I'm looking at
is actually polarization.
So in cases like the US or
even the UK, you know, it,
you might think it's
fine to discuss kind of
municipal budgeting, but if I
know that I'm gonna talk with
a bunch of out partisans,
like the opposing partisans
about Black Lives Matter
for a weekend, there are some
people that would say, no,
I don't wanna do that
because I'm effective part
polarization is so high.
And so understanding that
can help us like, you know,
keep the representative
benefits of the random sampling,
but make sure that we know
kind of our pools and stuff.
Yeah. Quickly, Kevin?
- [Kevin] Yeah so, I just,
I want somebody who study.
Somebody, do a study, please,
looking at how many people
they need when they have
stratified requirements.
- Yeah.
- We need these many people
who don't have a college
degree and so forth.
I want know how many people
did they have to ask.
What's the denominator?
- Yes.
- [Kevin] For the different
categories, right?
- Yeah. And you have
that and like, you know,
I talked to Helen about this,
like Iceland, you know,
the people who wanted
to do it were predominantly male
and educated, other places, you know,
and thinking about inclusivity,
like Belgium did paper mailings, right?
So they sent a letter
and I asked her like,
how'd the youth do, like how,
you know, would a youth get-?
And they said they actually
had like pretty good youth
participation, but like,
this is just like surveying
how you, how you recruit
actually influences
who participates like quite a bit.
Anyway, thank you very much.
We're gonna now move to
Federica who's gonna talk about,
again, historical collective governance.
So Federica, if you wanna come
on up and then again, coffee
and thank you.
(audience applauds)